a smart guy that understands simplicity
out of complex issues will just identify
the problem and walk around it the
problem is there's too many guys today
especially when it comes to personal
relationships inviting nightmares in
their life i had a you know a bunch of
private conversations with a whole bunch
of guys a lot of it was like you know i
invited this crazy chick in my life and
this that and the other thing happened
and now i'm dealing with the
consequences of that you see she's a
problem it walks like a duck it quacks
like a duck it's a duck if the [ __ ] is
crazy that's all you need to know it's
dressed like a red flag and it marches
like a chinese communist red flag parade
we're just not going to invite that into
our life that's really just the beauty
of the simplicity not inviting crazy in
your life who cares why it's crazy who
cares why that [ __ ] is there it's [ __ ]
you just walk around it i can save you a
lot of time and money just on that alone
that's it simplify your life cut off
anything that like comes at you in a far
too complex manner
you